going into the station
[Music]
Tristan Thompson and his daughter true
just put all other daddy-daughter dances
to shame I love it the NBA Pro and his
four-year-old daughter whom he shares
with his ex Khloe Kardashian showed off
their impressive moves on Instagram
Tuesday turning the kitchen into a dance
floor with Sean Mendes's hit there's
nothing holding me back blasting in the
background
[Music]
cute right well just wait because it
gets even cuter we all want to be cute
over here okay Tristan captioned the
adorable clip quote when my princess
asks if Daddy can dance anything for my
baby girl alongside a heart and crown
emoji
and while Chloe didn't comment on her
ex's post her bestie Malika hack did
writing quote I live you can't forget
that of course Chloe and Tristan called
it quits in 2021 after news broke that
he fathered a child with another woman
while he and Coco were together what a
crocodile like what the [ __ ] and I
believed you and I was listening to you
and I was receiving everything you said
figure
liar they have since welcomed a baby boy
via surrogate over the summer whose name
they have yet to reveal and naturally
the whole thing was documented on the
Family's Hulu series The Kardashians so
far it's going good he's perfect oh
thank you he looks just like true I
think a lot of what is in the media is
sort of things that we feel we need to
film because it's
in a way unfair to the viewers if they
don't get to see that and despite their
differences a source recently told E.T
Chloe and Tristan are doing a great job
at co-parenting adding that Tristan has
so much love for Chloe and always wants
her in his life quote things can be
tricky at times but they are doing their
best and are taking things one day at a
time and all that Echoes what Chloe told
E.T about raising kids back in 2019.
it's hard work for all parties I think
we come from a family where we believe
in that and you share children with
people and that's how it should be as
for True The Source adds that she is so
amazing as a big sister and already
shares a special bond with her new
sibling
you're gonna make the best big sister
ever do you know that and when it comes
to finding love
ET Source says Chloe isn't ruling it out
but her Focus right now is on her little
ones a sentiment she shared with ET back
in 2019 I'm just super happy and content
and I'm focused on true and I just I'm
having so much fun with her and when I
want to I will it's not some deliberate
thing that I think that hard about
with 2023 on the horizon we can't wait
to see how Tristan Coco true and baby
boy dance into the new year
[Music]